Just like you need to eat, drink and sleep to be able to wake up strong,...
...everything around us needs energy.
We get energy from two types of sources:...
...renewable and non-renewable.
One of these renewable energy sources is wind energy, which comes from the wind,...
...the natural resource you can find all over the planet and that is never-ending.
So you may be wondering, where does wind come from?
First, we need the sun.
The same rays that make you tan in summer are used to heat up the planet.
As the planet heats up, the air begins to be of different temperatures.
Hot air tends to rise and cold air tends to drop.
This movement of uneven air produces wind.
So far, so good.
Easy, right?
Now, the question is,...
...how can something we cannot capture with our hands generate energy?
When it is windy, we use wind turbines,...
...modern mills that transform the energy from the wind into electricity,...
...which is what reaches our homes so all of our appliances and devices can work.
Since the wind is a natural and never-ending resource,...
...wind energy is a clean and sustainable source of energy.
It reduces pollution as it doesn't produce any greenhouse gases,...
...and therefore, it helps us care for the environment and get the planet smiling.
To achieve all of this, we need at least one wind turbine.
They are called wind turbines or wind generators,...
...and you see them quite often when traveling on holiday by car.
The wind moves the blades, and as they rotate, they produce electricity.
Now you know it.
When the wind moves these turbines, you can turn on the lights when you get home,...
...use your computers and watch this video.